i hope you're all ready for a journey
hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another hazel
devlog
so as you guys know over the last few
weeks i've been just battling all of the
vulcan
issues because that's just my life now
whilst
i have fixed the majority of welcome
crashes as far as
i can tell the design of the renderer
itself is still not
exactly where i'd want it i mean i don't
think it's ever going to be where i'd
want it and unfortunately there are
still plenty of
other issues and i didn't really want to
get to that stage before we solved the
crashing because the crashing is kind of
the most
important thing to solve in the
beginning but now that we can run
without crashing properly
across all gpus as far as i can tell
we can move on to some of the more
interesting problems which is
why is everything so slow i mean isn't
vulcan supposed to be the fast api so
then why
is the vulcan renderer slower than the
opengl renderer
well let's investigate so the way that i
do these devlogs first of all is
retrospectively
so when i kind of say let's investigate
i've actually already done the
investigation
i actually know all the answers well all
the answers i can though so this is just
really like a bit of a story time with
cherno because i'm just telling you guys
a story and the story
begins with hitting f5 and taking a look
at the state of
hazeldev okay so let's take a look at
how fast we can render a moderately
complex scene in hazel at the moment
now first of all um for all of you who
were complaining that you can't
see anything i added a little bit of
like a large font
option here so that we can actually just
increase the font
let me just move this away for the
purposes of recording these videos kind
of like a presentation mode i guess so
uh
hopefully you'll be able to see now but
anyway i added this little performance
thing and the way that this works is
it's very easy in our c plus plus code
to just quickly add a macro basically
with a name in fact i'll show you what
that looks like if we
hop into like white and render as an
example right so
um it's hz scope perf it's basically
just the performance of a particular
scope it just starts a timer for the
scope of whatever scope you write this
code in and the way that this is set up
is that the name
is kind of i guess unique for the frame
so this is like a frame based timer so
in other words if i call a function
many times in the duration of like a
single frame
it will actually accumulate all of the
durations of that function in a given
frame because it gets reset once per
frame so
by using this we basically have pretty
decent cpu timings
of how long each function takes so just
keep an eye on that let's go ahead and
load like
the sponsor scene this is like a fairly
decent scene it's got about 1.1 million
indices in it
so here's how spawns are seen we're
rendering it with like you know cascaded
shadow maps i mean it's not the the most
complex thing there are no real
effects going on and you can see the
frame time this is in release mode is
like 26 to sometimes
30 milliseconds if i pause this for a
second 29.02 milliseconds right
now let's take a look at these timers
that i added so things like update for
rendering this is again this is called
for every single material
once per frame at the moment 0.2
milliseconds not too bad
wait and render takes about three
milliseconds so that's the entire render
command queue from the cpu side right so
recording
all of the vulcan command buffers takes
about three milliseconds
not great not terrible begin frame it
takes no time at all
swap chain present takes 25 or so
milliseconds
24.15 that time 24.4 that time you get
the point
it takes 24 milliseconds okay so what's
vulcan swap chain present all about
now i don't have any gpu timers in hazel
at the moment it's probably worth doing
but i've just been using profiling tools
so i haven't really
like um you know felt like a huge need
to actually add them
but i just want to like i just want to
make it clear that these are all
obviously cpu timers
however we can still use them to see how
long the gpu takes
because the way that swap chain present
works at the moment i've um
the latest version of hazel actually has
three flat three frames in flight
at any given time so we don't kind of
render one frame at a time we have
three frames up to three frames in
flight um so
but but for this example i've just i've
set it back to one frame but flies
really easy you can just set a number
um so i've set it to one frame per uh
one one frame in flight
at a time so that we can basically
sequentially see what's going on
so what this does then is basically
submits
everything to the gpu all of our command
buffers all of our stuff it gets
submitted to the gpu
and then we wait we have a fence that we
wait on there's one frame in flight so
we have to wait for that frame to finish
before we begin the next frame so after
we submit that cue
we spend 25 milliseconds ultimately
waiting i mean there's some like actual
q submission
does actually take time presentation
takes a little bit of time as well here
so vkq submit will take some time
present will take some time
but then the fence waiting is the the
majority of this time so
25 milliseconds we're literally waiting
for the gpu to finish its frame
so we know even though we don't have gpu
timers and again i
i can obviously bring this up and
profile it in and site and see what the
actual
you know what's actually going on and
how long the gpu is taking
but just through this data we can still
see that the gpu
is it's clearly the gpu's fault right
this is taking 25 milliseconds on the
gpu basically
compared to about three milliseconds on
the cpu
so why is the gpu taking so much time
and this is by the way
this was like my last i don't know i
don't want to say it was like two weeks
because
there were many other things i worked on
but over the last three or four days
this is basically this consumed me i did
not know
what was wrong and the thing is like you
know problems like these
it's kind of easy to isolate in a way
what's going on
but i still couldn't really solve it
quickly and i'll try i'll take you
through that journey now
so basically my first step and hopefully
this will kind of help you guys i try
and give you an in-depth view at how i
you know figure out all these issues so
that maybe you can apply it to your own
projects
that's kind of my hope but basically how
do we how do we
where do we begin with a problem like
this well the first thing is you have to
realize how your render is architected
right
in this case it's very bare bones
there's basically no optimization at all
i'm pretty sure
in this version there's no back yeah
there's no backface culling there's no
frustum culling there's no like draw
sorting
at all so we have tons of overdraw we
have
uh backface is not being culled and we
are
rendering the entire sponsor scene i
mean we're not shading the entire
sponsor scene because not all the pixels
are in view
but we are rendering we're submitting to
vulcan as a draw call
the entire model which is actually kind
of good
right i mean if i had for some calling
i'd probably turn it off because
um just to see because that that can
kind of interfere with your results
right i want to see
how long the gpu takes in like a raw
sense to actually render this entire
mesh because that's what i care about
so but we don't have it we don't have
any of that at the moment so we don't
need to deal with that
so my first concern was basically the
complexity of the pixel shader the
fragment shader complexity right so
is our fragment shader just too intense
right are we just doing
doing too many calculations there that
coupled with the overdraw which
basically just means that like
we might render something behind this
blue curtain
and then we'll render the blue cone in
front of it so in other words we're
calculating all the pixels
behind this and then that was a waste of
time turns out because there's a curtain
in front of it so that's why usually you
want to
sort from like front to back so that you
don't actually have so much overdraw
we're not doing that though as i
mentioned so it could just be the pixel
shader
really easy way to check though is to
just like try and make the area
smaller right so let's zoom out now
we're shading way less pixels right
in fact i could even just just take that
out right
or another strategy i could just resize
this and make it tiny
note the time basically hasn't changed i
mean it's changed a little bit
i know for a fact that that fragment
shader is not free
right there's a lot of stuff going on
there we're doing soft shadows for
multiple cascades we're fading the
cascades between each other
we're doing some pretty decent kind of
stuff inside that fragment shader
but obviously if we make this smaller
you can see it it's still above 20
milliseconds
i mean the i guess uh present false to
maybe under 20 milliseconds but it's
still kind of significant so ultimately
that's an easy way to just
rule that out completely but that wasn't
enough for me i was like okay
let's stop doing all of the complex
stuff in the fragment shader i just want
to see albedo only
unfortunately there's not really a ui
thing for that so if we go to
if we go to the shader we can basically
set the output color of our main kind of
forward pass
to actually just be like m params albedo
right like that if i go back we can rick
and past shaders on the fly
open up the shader hit reload good but
we're still at above 20 milliseconds
right so that kind of confirms what i
just showed you with the kind of fill
rate by just
making it less less pixels less
calculations
less times we run through the fragment
shader so therefore if it is the
fragment shader's fault you'd see a huge
performance increase
you'd probably see the same here because
we're just rendering us albedo
textures we're still doing the texture
lookups but you know i mean it doesn't
really matter we could
we could set the color to something like
um
[Music]
yeah and obviously the shader will
optimize out you know this this stuff
but we could
say we could ultimately just set it to
like white or something like that
it's still like 20 milliseconds let's
head back to albedo just so we can
actually see something
but you kind of get the point right it's
kind of it's not good so what is going
on here
okay well the next stage honestly for me
at least i'm not saying this is the
right way to go
about this but i was just playing around
with things i was like okay well we are
doing like
a bunch of these shadow passes right
this cascaded shadow map like situation
we're doing for
we're basically rendering this four
times so let's go ahead and kind of just
reduce the complexity
of this right that's all we're trying to
do right those shadow passes shouldn't
take that long
honestly but i don't know let's just
reduce the let's try and reduce this as
much as possible
let's go to the shadow map pass we know
we're not doing it anymore now we're
just doing geometry pass and the
compositing path that's it's very very
simple
right one thing we could have done is
also enabled hard shadows by the way
because that significantly
increases the performance but whatever
doesn't matter i try that as well
probably
okay so back to sponsor probably just
make it load on startup
but anyway six to seven milliseconds for
this i mean yes it's 1.1 million
triangles it's not
trivial we're not rendering a cube but
still
that's way too slow so my next step
was okay well let's find out what's
going on here and the presentation takes
about four milliseconds
this is a fast computer not the best
it's a 1080 ti
the gpu here fast enough now obviously
by the way i didn't mention this at the
beginning but obviously i have i'm
running in release mode
with not full cpu side optimizations
like i don't think i've enabled like
you know any suitable inline function
expansion or like inlining
or like um you know fast floating point
instructions and like ssa2 and stuff i
don't know if i'm actually if i've got
all that
enabled but it doesn't matter because we
don't care about the cpu but from the
gpu side aftermath is disabled
and vulcan validation is disabled falcon
validation
usually significantly increases the cpu
time
so i probably wouldn't have expected to
see much of a gpu difference anyway i'm
not really sure
what effect it has on the gpu but
usually it's kind of cpu side anyway so
it does have a huge effect on that so
that's all disabled
right we're basically running as fast as
possible here
why is it taking so long so next step
was let's profile this with
nvidia and sites frame profiler right so
you can actually i'll show you guys kind
of how this works you can actually
configure it
um just through insight which you can
all of course download um you need like
an nvidia developer account but that's
free you can get one of those just
register
um there's all these different like
types that you can kind of start
you know connect to process launch your
application fill in the application
executable the working directory that's
usually enough
um i didn't i don't really touch these
flags much
um but then there's this thing called
frame profiler right so what that does
is basically just
profiles your gpu to see how fast
things are running right and it can also
profile shaders
so i did that now i couldn't do that on
this computer because you need like a
turing gpu or higher for some reason if
you're trying to profile frames in
vulkan
i don't know if it's directx 12 as well
requires that but vulcan does
so you need basically like an rtx gpu my
laptop behind me
um has an rtx 2060 so i jumped on that
and i looked at the frame profile
now it's a little bit slow as 2016
mobile chip compared to like a
a desktop 1080 ti so it is a the
performance is different this is this
desktop is faster
so the frame times were a bit longer but
guys
that shadow map pass each cascade
six milliseconds
six milliseconds to do a depth only pass
of this of this thing right and if we
look at what is actually in there i mean
i've disabled my depth passes but you
saw like
it's just it's a cascade it's just it is
the full model usually maybe not i got
cascade
zero but a cascade one is the full model
but
six milliseconds what on earth is going
on and the thing is that right now now
that fragment shader
is the most simple there is no fragment
shader there's no like we're not even
like you know looking at the alpha of a
texture just to see if we should discard
those pixels
from the depth buffer no this is the
shader
i mean we've got a little to do there
maybe the comments the slow part right
but
there's nothing going on here why
why is it taking six milliseconds that
was my first
hint really and in retrospect that that
maybe should have triggered some idea
and i think now looking back on it
at this point i definitely would have
been like i know what's going on but i
didn't at the time
draw calls are slow that's the impact
basically i looked at each draw
as well you can look at each draw and it
was slow
each draw call was like point one
millisecond there's three hundred and
i don't know almost 400 draws in this
scene right
so what's going on i had no idea
honestly i think i looked at some other
videos to maybe
help me see what else inside might have
to figure this out i tried using um
there's something called gpu view which
is like a windows
performance toolkit kind of it looks at
your entire system
and you can kind of see what is going on
on the cpu the gpu
well gpu view specifically is for the
gpu stuff and you can kind of see what's
going on it's across all applications
but you can isolate it to your
application capture like a few seconds
and then see
um i even tried that i didn't really
want to go too far into that it's very
complex and very annoying to kind of
you know see what's up but then i
stumbled upon another nvidia thing
another nvidia thing which is also in
inside
by the name of gpu trace
now these two things are very similar
frame profiler gpu trace because gpu
trace also tells you timings
now you'll note that it doesn't support
the same apis opengl directx 11 not
supportive we just have d3d12 we have
vulkan
so this doesn't support everything also
needs a turing gpu so i couldn't run
on the desktop i had to run it on the
laptop but this
this thing right profile applications
use of gpu resources using a real-time
capture of detailed metric data
this thing is way more detailed than
frame profiler
and what i've done is i've actually i've
actually run it behind me it's still
open there
i captured three frames using it over
there and i transferred the file here
onto this computer so that i could
actually show you guys
what's up so let's take a look at it
this is what i saw
now this looks very daunting and i'll be
honest if you're not like
if you if you have no idea how gpus how
gpu architecture works
this is this is going to be very
difficult to look at
i'm not going to even pretend to
understand half of what's going on here
but i do understand a little bit and
with some googling
you can also kind of find out but these
are my three frames right
now what i what i did on that laptop to
capture this before i did that is i
isolated the problem again i said forget
the shadow passes the ridiculous shadow
passes
let's just worry about an albedo-only
main kind of pass which is kind of what
you see here
that's what i did and you can kind of
see it in the corner that's what the
capture looks like it looks very
widescreen because it's on that like
ultrawide monitor but basically i did
that
so you can see here this is my
submission um
i think i probably only had one frame in
flight
maybe i don't remember but anyway we
have our q submission we have our
command buffer we have our 396
draw calls which took 6.21 milliseconds
albedo only draw calls
6.21 milliseconds very slow
so what did i notice here well first of
all you know we're looking for huge
numbers now
now we see a bunch of stuff going on
here we see a lot of stuff not being
utilized much
but this kind of blue thing this pci
throughput seems through the roof
94 percent now for those of you who
don't know pci pcie is kind of the
that's how we connect the graphics card
to the motherboard so that bus
is how the gpu gets information that's
how it gets data through the motherboard
from like cpu ram for example
goes through the pcie bus right that
much i knew
um i don't know what pes plus vpc
throughput is
but pci i know i know what that is so
that that's good
right but if i didn't know i'd google it
because this is like clearly
more important than this probably right
we can see that the pci throughput is
very high
the other thing i noticed so we have
sm which is streaming multi-processors
again a bit of like gpu architecture
which i'm not going to explain
at the moment and warps as well warps
are basically like little units of
execution it's basically like
you know when we like render something
and we have a fragment shader which
dispatches like a bunch of like threads
to actually calculate pixels they're
called
warps those kind of like units of
execution
so warp can't launch and it says ps warp
can't launch so
pixel shader warp can't launch 99.7
and it's like that for like the whole
like the frame ends here right this is
where the draw calls end
it's it's pretty much like that the
entire duration
so clearly this is somehow just it can't
launch
why why would a pixel shader warp not be
able to launch
maybe because it's waiting on like the
vertex shader to finish or it's waiting
on
it's waiting on something right very
suspicious right
pci bandwidth another little red flag
look how high that is
pci right pci read
what's going on right why is it why is
bad why is why is there so much stuff
going on with the pci bus
now the first thing that i thought of
the first thing i thought of is
am i like streaming these textures in
every frame am i updating like
i don't know maybe there's a bug in my
code where i'm actually like
just re-uploading all of my textures
every frame or something ridiculous like
that
right didn't really make sense to me
because i mean
if i reduce the color to white it's not
sampling any textures anymore
right so then you know why is it still
taking so much time
so i honestly i had no idea why i had no
idea why this was happening
so i hit up a friend of mine i worked
with him at ea
and i sent him like a little screenshot
of this and i was like do you have any
idea why my pci throughput
might be so high and you know what
he came back to me immediately and he
said it sounds like your vertex and
index buffers
are being stored in system ram
and that hit me like a ton of bricks i
was like
my vertex buffers on my cpu ram
no and i quickly opened up the code
i quickly went to vertex buffer.cpp
and to my shock and horror
my memory usage was set to cpu only
now i swear
it was not like that all the time
because
i think this may have somehow happened
because i was copying and pasting code
from around the engine
when i switched to using vma which is
like the vulcan memory allocator it's
basically like a
a memory allocator you can use on top of
vulcan that actually like
allocates memory and keeps track of it
by itself because you can only like
provide 4096 allocations but anyway
vulcan memory allocation is
is an interesting topic but anyway i
didn't always use vma i switched to it
about a month ago
um but ever since doing that i guess
like i had to refactor my code obviously
for that and i guess i somehow i don't
know
this must have just somehow slipped in
and index buffer
is the same that's opengl index buffer
is the same
right we have our cpu only
well i felt nice when i saw that
and the thing is what's also interesting
is that look at this
poor excuse of a vertex buffer class
because this was like one of those
things this is probably left over minus
the vma stuff from like vulcan week
like a year ago or something when i was
like okay let's set this up
vertex buffers let's just upload them
done you know we don't care about it i
didn't need to like dynamically update
vertex buffer
buffers or like map the memory or do
anything yet um
none of that stuff i guess exists and
the vulcan implementation of hazeldev at
least we don't really do any 2d
rendering i think
so this is just the way that it was
right
for whatever reason i mean there's no
like we don't even have a destructor in
this class this was so abandoned it was
so old
so then when i saw this i was like well
this is a disaster let's change this
so you can't just change this to like
gpu or anything i mean i will say that
the g and the c those two letters are
suspiciously
similar looking they mean very different
things
um you can't change it to like gpu only
without using staging buffers which is
like the correct solution and
now actually in the latest version of
hazel i have switched this around to
staging buffers but as a quick test what
i did you can just do cpu 2 gpu
right it'll upload it to the gpu it'll
be there
it's not going to live in the cpu
forever let's go ahead and switch that
out
for index buffers as well just that
that one little flag from cpu
or from cpu only to cpu to gpu
right let's go ahead and open sponsor
and my gosh look at that difference one
millisecond on presents that was a bad
pause one millisecond on present down
from like
four right and again we're not doing
shadow passes
let's go ahead and enable our shadow
passes and let's go ahead and
also change the shader around as well
to uh not just be albedo
and just change that shader
reload the shader and there we go
and you can see that now with this in
this view
we're down to like 9 to 10 milliseconds
from like 22
right and you can see our presentation
now this is like again we're doing
i've reduced it to just one frame in
flight so this cpu time
if i set it to like three again it'll
kind of get like
you know it'll be happening at the same
time so we'd be even faster
but you can see that it's made a massive
difference now there's still tons of
overdraw
right there's still lots of stuff going
on that
isn't ideal but that one little thing
right and after that i think now the
shadow map passes take like less than a
millisecond
each compared to like six it's scary
it's scary to think that that enum right
was set to the wrong value
that one little that little piece of
code was being set to like one
just the number one instead of the
number two and that little thing
that little little flag
just ruined everything and to be honest
that's the scary thing with vulcan this
would not have happened in open shell i
don't even know if it's possible
to store your vertex and index buffer
memory on your cpu ram
is that possible i'd i've never done it
i honestly don't know
but with vulcan it's so verbose it's so
detailed that i am honestly scared at
what else could be lurking in my code
that i just missed i want one little
thing
that just completely destroyed anything
and the thing is like i haven't run this
through some kind of like i don't know
if there's like vulcan validators or
some kind of
like the validation layer obviously
didn't say anything um it could have
been like hey man
your vertex buffer is like on your cpu
ram that's probably not optimal because
i know opengl
i think through the debug message
callback can give you like some hints or
some warnings
didn't see anything from vulkan i don't
know maybe i'm just doing errors only
who knows maybe i'm a clown i am a clown
but that's that's besides the point
i d it is really scary and to be honest
i'm so happy that this is now running
quickly um
oh and sorry one last thing now
we can really see if it's the fill rate
i'll zoom out and oh sorry i forgot my
little
video mode look at that
11 milliseconds four milliseconds right
so you can see now that now we are
actually bound by that fragment shader i
can reduce this even more
right it's about well now actually where
cpu bound look at that present
0.9 milliseconds that's doing all of the
cascades
but it's taking about one millisecond
now we're actually cpu bound right
so yeah
that's life you do one little thing
and everything explodes
insight is fantastic first of all
because how do you
even find this stuff like there isn't
there would be no way
for me to find this i i would have had
to read all of my code i would have
never thought that the vertex buffer
class was doing that
right it just i maybe i'm not
experienced with vulcan enough i mean
clearly not but
i just wouldn't have even thought to
look there but opening up
gpu trace and then actually seeing that
pci throughput being
through the roof extremely extremely
valuable
but anyway that was my week
so i hope you guys enjoyed this little
devlog i'm so happy that i've solved
these performance issues because
i was really worried about the the the
performance of the vulcan renderer and
hazel
because actually the opengl renderer was
faster
it's not faster anymore especially with
multiple frames and flight in the vulcan
renderer
but it was like twice the speed and now
i know why it's because my
in in opengl land i was storing my
vertex and index buffers on the gpu
but in vulcan i was storing them on the
cpu and so as is going through
and drawing every piece of geometry it
needs access to that vertex buffer
where does it get it from through the
pci bus from cpu ram
and that is why it was slow anyway
hope you guys enjoyed this little devlog
story time
with jonah let me know what you thought
let me know if you've had this problem
before you know
let me know if maybe what i'm help what
i'm doing here is actually helping you
um you know kind of diagnose issues in
your own engines because that's kind of
you know i mean first and foremost like
it's obviously fun for me to show what
i'm working on and then it's fun for
people to follow along but i also
you know hope that some of this is
useful to the people who might be in the
same position because again making
engines
is is difficult and um
and yeah like i think the community
should be around to help each other as
much as possible but anyway
thanks for watching don't forget you can
help support hazel by going to
patreon.com
slash the channel you'll get access to
all of this source code you'll be able
to
look at the vulcan renderer in all of
its quick
quicker glory now there's still a lot of
work to do with that but i think that
i'm content enough to start moving on to
some other features and not necessarily
optimization
um although that will come pretty soon
but the huge thank you to everyone who
helps support on patreon that's why this
all this is possible
um yeah devlog monday i'll see you next
[Music]
week
[Music]
you